hello guys I'm Ryan right I'm Danielle
yes I love it
personality so Danielle and I are gonna
check out from Deibert three two one
five incredibly disturbing things on the
Deep Web have you heard of the site for
Chan no 4chan and people make like some
crazy posts on there like I've heard
about one post where a guy was like I'm
gonna commit suicide he did a live
stream of it and there's like other
horrible things about like killers
anyway so then people were like if you
have seen if you don't know what 4/10 is
[ __ ] man just keep a lookout for when
you learn about the Deep Web oh so I'm
like alright this must be really [ __ ]
up and since Halloween is around the
corner let's do this the deep wave is
the part of the internet that cannot be
accessed through standard search engines
it's accessed through tor which offered
privacy to those who used it
however this newfound privacy was
quickly taken advantage of by criminals
who could now conduct crimes over the
Internet in peace the Deep Web became a
hub that grew disturbing communities and
web sites for that reason I've compiled
a list of just that before and begin
though I'd like to warn you that these
disturbing stories features very graphic
imagery an armored hide toned down
triggering material in most of these
creepy videos because I'm not trying to
put you in mental asylums here but with
the Deep Web it was almost unavoidable
but if you're still here sit back relax
tape your webcams and join me for five
incredibly disturbing things on the Deep
Web kind of excited dude the Red Room
someone working at a gas station details
his experience with the Deep Web he was
given an onion link from a guy who often
shopped there he decided to browse the
Deep Web and after clicking countless
hyperlinks he stumbled upon what
appeared to be a live stream there were
up to 200 people logged into the
chatroom most of who were prompting the
live stream to start there was also a
user that was highlighted who appeared
to be the director of the stream when
the stream began there were two men
standing and a woman who was tied up the
director prompted the men to hit her and
continue to leave malicious commands
until
eventually telling them to gouge out her
eyes oh my oh I'm talking every type
something into the chopper
yeah which read the words 500 more
that's when the gas station employee
came to the chilly realization that they
were doing this live stream for a mere
500 dollars the director agreed to this
amount and the men carried out his
wishes eventually killing her after
which a chilling message popped up in
the chat box
it read thanks for watching next live
stream one our number two is sad Satan a
game that apparently started on the
surface web until it was taken down it
was brought back to life by the reddit
community as they tried to unravel the
mystery behind this game after this the
game was remade only it was placed on
the Deep Web due to its new features
containing very disturbing content
interests the new content featured
disturbing audio which if listened to
could make the player sick it also
featured child pornography and child
brutality if you're thinking of playing
it make sure you play it on safe mode a
certain players have explained they
still feel sick when thinking about the
imagery and audio of the game expose
them to number 3 is human experience the
idea that terrible human experiments
riddled the Deep Web might be slightly
fabricated but it does exist and this
story is a good example of the messed up
things that can happen on the Deep Web
after browsing around someone found what
appeared to be a website dedicated to
human experiments the owners of the site
kidnapped people brought them to various
warehouses and conducted horrific
experiments on them the victims were
usually homeless people but it also
ranged from toddlers to teenage oh the
experiments were usually to see how much
pain a human being could sustain before
dying
one guy browsing the website saw chat
box pop up the owner of the site was on
the other end the guy was asked if he
liked the site when he said it was sick
and he was gonna call the cops
the owner responded quickly with the
guy's name and his entire address the
guy visiting decide quickly exited and
called the cops because tor doesn't save
any history all traces of the site were
gone from the computer and impossible to
act
the guy decided to move house as he
feared whoever owned the site were find
them the site is only available now
through archived websites however the
people who ran it haven't been caught
and are more likely still operating in
some way number four is pay the price
the deeper you get when browsing the
dark web the more likely you are to find
websites that have tough layers of
security sites you can only enter with
the membership which is extremely
difficult to obtain so for the most part
we'll never really know what's going on
in the absolute deepest parts of the
Internet however one brave Reddit user
might have changed that as they've been
to the depths of the web and have come
back to detail their experience they
began receiving information by talking
to some shady individuals in various
chat rooms they had some phone calls but
eventually they got invited to visit one
of the restricted web sites before they
were allowed to enter they have to go
through a number of tests and have to
have a one-on-one Skype call with the
admin they eventually got in and found
out it was a video sharing service that
allowed people to upload videos and sell
them to those interested to merely be a
member of the site you have to pay the
equivalent of three hundred and fifty
dollars in Bitcoin even then you still
have to pay to watch the videos that
were uploaded the person who was
visiting the website bought access to
one of these videos and quickly found
out why this website was so heavily
secured they were distributing snuff
films the one the visitor stumbled upon
featured a group of men attacking and
killing a homeless man in an alley the
visitor quickly left the site but their
experience shows us an example of the
system used in the darkest parts of the
Deep Web number 5 is real-life dolls in
2012 at 4chan user posted an account of
his personal experience on the Deep Web
he said that he found a website that
sold real-life dolls in his post he said
that the web site was made by a surgeon
tapped and abused girls as young as 10
the surgeon would then strip away their
sense of smell taste and hearing and
remove their teeth so they could not
speak he then sold them for up to
$40,000 a lot of 4chan users chose not
to believe
posed as there was no evidence backing
it and it was a bit too messed up it was
also said it was impossible to find
unless you randomly found it through the
hidden wiki's countless hyperlinks it
was dismissed until somebody actually
found it and were smart enough to take a
screen cap the website turned out to be
even creepier than the 4chan user
explained as it details very thoroughly
the messed up surgeons operation
although it has been found people still
believe the website is somebody's messed
up idea of a joke and hopefully that's
true and that's it for this video guys I
don't think I've ever been happier to
end a video because god dammit there are
some messed up people out there
regardless I hope you enjoyed and if you
did don't forget that hit that like
button and possibly consider subscribing
though it could be fun you never know
either way I'll see you in the next
video and I hope you enjoyed your taped
webcam doesn't really make sense
reaction that was some pretty dark [ __ ]
man oh god what do you think it all
happened I'm saying like what state what
state Florida yeah this is all so creepy
a man they were all you loves I like
scary too but this is like real [ __ ] of
people actually like the first one with
yeah how they like killed someone and
people are like paying for this
livestream for only 500 bucks but hate
to say it's kind of a deal that's so
disrespectful
I'm sorry I hate to admit it but you
know [ __ ] it let's just be a little bit
more unique than everyone else okay
there is something tempting about
looking at this stuff oh my god yeah
because it's out there and available I
don't necessarily want to support it and
help it grow no but a part of me kind of
wants to check out like something on
there remember that website that you
would forget what it's called but it's
web so you go to and
had pictures of like debt like dead
bodies like one like a train ran over or
someone who was decapitated but like
real light like real pictures I know oh
oh I used to look at it when I was a kid
all the time Oh Did you touch yourself
to that okay Danny no I did not but it
was creepy and cool not cool the Satan
game can you actually can we play that
apparently how do we get there to play
it you want to play it yeah I want to
see if I really will be there's like
child pornography and stuff in there
there's like real things in there okay
you really want to test out if you're a
child pornography that wasn't the mean
play that child pornographer let's see
if I can say it was not the main part
the other stuff I'll fast-forward with
child pornography I'll make you feel
better
that would make you feel oh my god
better I'll go fast over that dark video
dark humor goes hand-in-hand people oh
we're gonna go to hell yeah well I don't
believe I do believe in heaven and I
gotta admit the third story about how
they would like take homeless people and
perform crazy human experiments on them
I feel like that would be an interesting
movie to watch I feel like there's
movies that are similar along those
lines but you know imagine a trailer for
it and you're like based on a true story
yeah that would be terrifying
Hollywood I'm trying to give you an idea
seriously that would be so creepy but
like that's such a good idea
no not like to really do to people don't
laugh because you actually think it is
please don't don't be dumb let that be
the reason you're laughing just be
careful what you say to him the
real-life dolls one I hate to say this
but it's true I can see you being a
real-life doll me yeah I could see you
being a real-life doll
I don't think you'd be sold for 40,000
though more or less probably a lot less
I'm thinking like at least cut down like
30%
oh not know but okay so if you really
think about it like who would want that
people will be like these people are
sick but there's also a yeah obviously
but there's also this other part where
if you're participating in and buying in
fascination with something is one thing
participating in it totally different
story if you're buying live babies yeah
no sense of anything yeah then you just
got like to be boring human beings yeah
baby
I'm willing to make jokes as they said
they don't know if that's 100% true yeah
we don't know for sure so well yeah I
mean we gotta learn about the deep web
today very fascinating ones dude can I
go into the deep boy whatever I want I
don't know how to access the Deep Web
but I know it's real they have heard of
this [ __ ] before divots actually see
like imagery just stills of like little
things was like Omar you gotta go and
Majan what you actually see yeah it was
creepy but I really wouldn't like to
access the Deep Web that sometimes when
I was young there was this Highway
Patrol chase happening and then a guy
got out of the car and then blew his
head off and the cameras didn't pull
away in time and I was kind of
traumatizing for me to see a guy blow
his head off on live TV yeah I've seen a
lot of heads being blown off in movies
better when you see like real violence
it's so something totally difficult yeah
that horrible thing that just happened
in the news person on TV the reporter
and the disgruntled guy who worked in
the news station and he came and he shot
her during her you know about that I'm
live TV I didn't know about that
everywhere for a very long time it's all
any was a huge news story
I only browse the Yahoo entertainment
section I can't believe it wasn't there
not in the entertainment section
anywhere you would go it would be there
don't you get CNN alerts to your phone
you don't get CNN if you guys are new to
the channel you can subscribe today and
become a reject reject
reject reject anus and Danielle can't
promote anything for her she's just a
friend who's here with me today but why
don't you guys leave some comments about
what you think she can do with her life
besides porn don't make porridge on
jokes no more porn jokes yeah no I don't
want people to be talking about you
doing a porno why because what if you
feel inspired and then you decide to do
it and then you just ruin everyone's
life by watching this porn porn
actresses make money what sound like to
bane [ __ ] they don't make money get
enough views same thing with YouTube you
could pack in some dough I know the
YouTube world imagined what I can do
with the pong world
can you put porn on YouTube no you
definitely can't but I have a depends